en el último vídeo establecimos este
integral para calcular el volumen de
este sólido para lo cual usamos el
método de cascarones por lo que ahora
evaluemos esta integral para esto voy a
simplificar esta expresión empezaré
simplificando esto que tenemos aquí
entre paréntesis
tenemos entonces que es que uno
algo algo innato en la garganta una
manzana que acaba de comer discúlpame
menos que cuadrada menos 21 he
desarrollado este binomio al cuadrado y
aquí que tenemos esto al ser yemas 1 que
más 1 vamos a quitar el paréntesis menos
ye cuadrada más 2 - 1
y aquí agrupando términos semejantes
este 1 y este menos 1 se cancelan y que
nos resulta menos y cuadrada y ye más
dos es más 3 y ahora multipliquemos esta
expresión por ye más 2 que nos va a dar
vamos a multiplicar entonces jeff por
menos de cuadrada que por menos de
cuadrada nos va a dar menos que kubica
menos que kubica luego y por 3 y nos va
a dar más tres que cuadrada
continuamos con dos por menos de
cuadrada dos por menos iguales menos dos
que cuadrada finalmente dos por tres y
nos va a dar más 6
ahora aquí abajo vamos a hacerlo
agrupamos estos términos 3 llegó a menos
2 igualdades igual adecuada entonces nos
resulta menos kubica más 3 y cuadrada
menos 2 y cuadrada es igual a ye
cuadrada más y cuadrada y más 6 y así
que esto que tenemos aquí es lo que
hemos desarrollado por acá abajo sacamos
dos pi del integral y nos va a quedar
esta expresión que vamos a integrar de 0
a 3 de iu x 2 pi y eso es igual a
nuestro volumen
vamos entonces a resolver esta integral
esto va a ser igual a 2 y encontramos la
anti derivada la anti derivada de toda
esta expresión evaluada en 3 y luego le
vamos a restar evaluada en 0 entonces
que tenemos la anti derivada de menos de
kubica y lo voy a hacer con un código de
colores la anti derivada de menos de
kubica es menos de cuarta sobre cuatro
más la anti derivada de ye cuadrada que
es que kubica sobre tres finalmente lo
voy a hacer en color amarillo la anti
derivada de 6 y la antidiva de serie que
es 3 y cuadrada más 3 y cuadrada y eso
lo voy a evaluar de 0 a 3
que nos resulta entonces esto va a ser
igual a 2 y que multiplica menos de
cuarta entre 4 evaluado en 3 que sería
menos 3 a la cuarta menos 3 a la cuarta
que es 81 cuartos más que kubica sobre 3
y kubica es 27 sobre 3 es igual a 9 más
3 porque cuadrada 3 por 9 es 27
aquí tenemos entonces más 27 que a todo
esto le vamos a restar la expresión
evaluada en 0 pero no tenemos que cuando
llévale 0
la expresión vale cero simplificamos
ahora esta expresión vamos a hacer
entonces esta suma de fracciones para
esto nos conviene sumar primero 9 27
entonces la suma de 927 nos va a dar 36
así es que esto nos va a resultar 81
cuartos más 36 y para hacer esto
necesito sacar un común denominador así
que esto va a ser igual a 2 pi el común
denominador de estos dos términos
es igual a 4 y en el numerador que
tenemos menos 81 de menos 81 cuartos más
36 en cuartos 4 por 36 esto es igual a
144 si 144 a ver si queremos 4 por 30
120 4 por 6 24 ok 144 y ahora vamos a
restar 81 de 144 por lo que ahora
tenemos entonces que es igual a 2 pi
pero espérate por simplificar más esto
sí aquí tengo 4 y aquí tengo 22 entre 2
es igual a 1 y 4 entre 22 en el
denominador esto nos va a resultar pi y
cuánto nos da 144 menos 81 a ver veamos
si fueran 144 menos 80 sería 64 pero
como es 81 tenemos 63 así es que aquí
tenemos 63 vamos a poner lo mejor de
esta manera esto es igual a 63 y medios
a ver lo hice bien 60 más 81 serían 141
más 3 144 si está
63 y medios es el volumen de nuestro
sólido con forma de frente de turbina de
jet